die familie hier das ist fast wie geht s
einfach drei verschiedene familien wir
sind alle gleich aus erinnert was geht
ab und jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
unfassbar genialen video heute mal mit
einem casting hier wahrscheinlich noch
gar nicht kennt ja dieses video entsteht
eigentlich ziemlich spontan und zwar
haben wir uns im video gerade angeschaut
da geht es erst mal um optische
täuschungen also nichts interessant ist
das gibt's ja auf youtube auch schon
milliarden für aber in dem video kam so
ein na ja ich sag mal was sagt man dazu
wenn man immer so zwei gleichzeitig
memory memory also wir drehen heute ein
video zum thema
so kannst du mal kurz erklären um was
ist genau geht das ganze wird in fünf
sekunden 1 10 sekunden wir schauen uns
jetzt ein video an und da sind immer
ganz ganz viele muttis und ein energy
gibt es immer dann müssen wir erstellen
wer schneller ist man kann sich schnell
auf jeden fall müssen wir erraten welche
das ist beziehungsweise raus in welcher
das ist und wer schneller ist hat
gewonnen und ich hab für alex anderen
paar rausgesucht
ihr habt so verklärt nein das war nur
deutlich zu lang aber ich will gar
nichts sagen weil ich rede auch mal sehr
viel also die ich jetzt noch nicht
verstanden haben was ich verstehen kann
also das ist doch nicht verstanden haben
die werden jetzt gleich verstehen und
ich würde sagen wir fangen an bis wir
ein mann hat dann anders zu erwarten
auch immer nur zehn sekunden zeitnah
also passt
[Musik]
hast du eigentlich darf man gar nicht
stark machen
ich weiß es nicht ich wollte erst sagen
der da oben der den großen unter das war
jetzt einfach mal ein kurzer beispiel
durch laub so geht das dh diese beiden
images werden jetzt theoretisch gleich
gewesen
ja und das ist eigentlich voll krass
weil normalerweise man denkt halt dass
man das vorsieht aber man sieht einfach
nur genau
also das war der erste durchgang
jetzt hat wahrscheinlich jeder
verstanden und wir starten jetzt in
einem zweiten okay okay ich gehe so alle
von oben nach links durch aber ich sag
hot dog and wait stimmt also also an
alle die jetzt handy kommentare
geschrieben haben
herzlichen glückwunsch ich habe es nicht
gedeckt ist doch mega schwer 1 0 für
dich will man sieht das war klar
das kamel das eine habe ich auch gesehen
[Musik]
ich hab' ich hab's ich hab's ich hab's
ich hab's ich hab was sagst du und ich
sage die katze und zwar haben wir hier
einmal die katze und daher die katze dh
alex mit seinen lux augen sofort er kann
also eins zu eins wir machen weiter mit
dem nächsten
[Musik]
irgendwie geht mit warte mal ich muss
mal kurz diese musik heraus machen die
geht mir auf den sack
reddy so das nächste
ich wollte sagen die brille aber die
brille ist ja einfach anders hast du
okay dann mache ich jetzt dann mach ich
jetzt hier stoppt und der als erstes
jetzt das gerät der hat hier waren okay
da gibt es nix doppeltes doch ich hab
ich hab' ich habs auf den mantel
ja ich habe das gemacht
man würde ich jetzt auch sagen
wahrscheinlich hast du die brille gehabt
okay okay dann steht ja immer noch ein
paar ski immer noch 1 1 okay okay wir
machen weiter so das ist schwer
ich wollte gerade sagen lizenz oder aber
die rechtliche handhabe
ich hab's ich hab's und zwar ist es die
willst du auch noch was sagen sonst sage
ich jetzt die surferin hier einmal und
hier
die skizze von weil es geht sofort
weiter ok ich schlecht was hast du nicht
ich hab mein dieses auto
das lässt ja leute also wir haben jetzt
hier entstand von zwei her das war es
jetzt schon jetzt ist es schon vorbei
oder was ja anscheinend aber ich habe
für dich ja noch das ausgesucht der
merkwürdig selbst so ein kreis erstellt
wir uns jetzt jetzt nämlich beide
gleichstand für uns steht jetzt bei
gleichstand ja also das war die idee
dahinter ich ärgere mich jetzt gerade
irgendwie ein bisschen dass das jetzt
schon vorbei ist ich kommentiere jetzt
einfach mal mach mal noch ein paar ja
und ich würde sagen bevor wir jetzt das
video hier schon beenden das gerade mal
34 minuten geht hast du mir noch was
raussuchen
also leute die machen jetzt
folgendermaßen weiter du zählst immer
von 10 bis nun runter okay lass ich mal
dahin wünsche ich nicht und wir schauen
uns dann hier jetzt erst mal die demo zu
crysis an die werden immer hierüber
maries gesicht ein gebinde damit wir
auch irgendwie das video noch ein
bisschen auf werden können das selbst
aus diesem montag mit seinem gelben
pulli stimmt du musst von zehn runden
und hier bei 15,52
[Musik]
ich hab's alle events online ich wollte
mir so hinter diesem schritt - 1 - 2
minus 3 bis minus ich hab ich nicht habe
ich habe ihn mir diesen der so machte
der halt negativ ist weißt du den und
dem die beiden hier online die sage ich
gar nicht was ich sag ja das ist schwer
das zu erstellen ich habe denen
eigentlich gar nicht gemeint ich habe
eigentlich den und dem da waren einfach
zwei gleiche drin also und du hast die
beiden einbringen um mein geld ja das
ist echt schwer weil die ganze zeit was
halt selber häufig mutig sie alle
irgendwie gleich aussehen und ok ich
werde ja gut dann kriege ich hier keinen
punkt weil ich habe es ja auch nicht in
der zeit geschafft ach so ok kommentiert
gerne habt ihr den richtigen gefunden
oder nicht von der eigenen von den
richtigen oder ein von dem zum richtigen
wieder eingebaut und ok oder
beziehungsweise kommentiert weil sie
noch ein pärchen gefunden habt ja okay
ein mittel sind jetzt sind 13 12 876 432
die hand
nein ist es nicht die hand es ist nicht
die hand oder nein die ist anderes aber
schaut euch mal diese hand an ich weiß
ja mit dem swing sagte die sehen alle
gleich aus
die sind alle gleich seien gekommen
herrmann wir nicht schlecht wie viele es
nur noch zwei okay okay wir kommen zum
vorletzten ok 15
der kommissar ja das ist ja wirklich
schaut euch mal diesen kommentaren
kommissar oben in der ecke an das ist ja
echt 11 fast die gleiche smiley oder
hier dieser komische erlebte diese
längst auch gleich oder komplettem und
auftreten und zu habe ich mir auch über
den 1 87
ich wusste gar nicht das ist alles meine
es gibt ich hab's diese bauarbeiter bei
mir ist es nicht überhaupt weiteren dem
kochen dekorieren die köchin die köche
ok wenigstens einen punkt und zwar haben
wir hier einmal in der mittleren reihe
ganz rechts die köchin und diese auch
eine reihe über relativ das dritte von
links okay ein hast du noch nicht so
leute wir kommen zur nächsten runde
duden ex-frauen und die man früher mal
gesagt hat beim fußballtraining bei uns
das letzte tor entscheidet weil er
selbst wenn die 1 mannschaft dann schon
10 uhr geführt hat und die andere
mannschaft aber das letzte tor
geschossen hat hat die trotzdem gewonnen
dieses prinzip wenn wir heute auch an
ihrem video das heißt wenn ich das jetzt
erwarte habe ich automatisch geworden
bin viel cooler sind jetzt wird 20
sekunden zwei okay sagen wir 15 sekunden
15 13
das ist folgt verbindet auf eins und
zwei jungs die sich lieber auf anderen
sind so ich hab ich hab's ja ganz
einfach wir haben ja einmal das hier und
das hier welches das und das erwartet
dann suche ich das andere ist auch noch
raus weiter zählen die familie hier gibt
es einfach drei familien wir sind alle
gleich aus die jungs die jungs hier der
und der ja als ich komme wirklich nicht
klar darauf was whatsapp tut das waren
halt so oder dass jede randgruppe sag
ich mal
da jetzt zufrieden ist mit wir haben ja
einmal wir haben ja einmal einfach 22
erwachsene männer mit zwei kindern dann
haben wir zwei erwachsene frauen mit
zwei kindern man hat auch dann haben wir
cooper man hat auch zwei erwachsene
männer mit einmal einen medien einem
jungen 2002 jürgens 2 wachsen
ich glaube was sage ich denn jetzt wenn
ich sage meinen eltern ja klar aber ich
sag mal so theoretisch würde ja auch
einfach ein familien smile die reichen
und nicht jetzt mal diesem motto zwei
jungs das herz so zwischen haben klar
das kann man ja machen weil man muss
jetzt nicht ab verschiedene varianten
von irgendwelchen familien da und er ja
noch dass sie sich küssen dann küssen
sich hier die zwei jungs dann küssten
sich hier die zwei mädchen und
wahrscheinlich hast du noch irgendwo
drücken gleich eine handvoll gut sein
ja das ist ein echt schwer guck mal wie
sich doch selber und das waren sie
selber zu erstellen
leicht da ist ja was war es mit dem
video wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr
sagt alex macht doch bitte noch eine
folge last auf jeden fall den daumen
nach oben da und schreibt unter das
video von sieben sekunden rätsel was ich
euch in der video schränkt verlinkt hat
haye alex möchte gern noch ein paar alex
kann er auch mal recht machen mal gucken
ob da in der bauten sind noch mehr pech
hinein ich wünsche euch einen schönen
tag schaut gerne bei uns bei instagram
vorbei und folgte uns da und wir sehen
uns nicht morgen wieder aber morgen
abonnieren ich vergessen schaut das
video von gestern hat rein